all right guys
bang bang i think i have the like
twitter bad boy on the episode today
this guy literally says whatever the
hell he wants
uh mike is here thank you so much for
doing this man yeah thanks for having me
all right we're just gonna start with
the two most important questions
everyone wants to know
i ask every billionaire that comes on
the podcast how did you
what did you do when you got your first
billion dollars you are the newest
billionaire what did you do
oh my god um if i got into a flame war
that was like the very first thing that
i did
i mean honestly that's probably never
gonna change
i do think i mean on the billionaire
thing i i mean
if there is a sort of like digital
currency now um
that only that only sort of makes sense
on the internet it does not have
anything to do with the real world
it reminds me of uh so in snow crash
the dude the like pizza delivery guy
is rich as hell inside of the virtual
reality world he's super rich
but in the real world he lives inside of
like a crate like that it's like it's
like one of these yes
like shipping crates um he's super poor
but it doesn't matter because
we're living online now and so that kind
of wealth
means something so i don't know maybe i
am a maybe i am a kind of billionaire
maybe lorena was on to something
when uh when i saw this and i'll get to
tell the story in two seconds but
uh i saw all these other people you know
joking around or whatever
but the most prescient comment that i
saw was somebody was like uh
everyone focuses on a billionaire in
terms of dollars but actually we should
think of it as seconds in your life
right so the younger you are the richer
you are
and uh the way that they framed it was
um you think warren buffett is rich
would you trade for his amount of money
if you also had to trade to be his age
right and if not then you're richer
right and so i was like okay fair but
like that's not what she was talking
about she literally was talking about
mike's a billionaire
yeah well i mean okay so i mean the
backstory is just right i get into this
flame war with a politician
it's the politician responsible for ab5
which is this bill
in california that effectively once
gavin newsom signed it
put out of work potentially millions of
people if it were
followed the law makes independent
contracting work effectively illegal
um it's just like no one listened to it
because they were like this is too crazy
you can't just there's no way that our
politicians meant for it for this to
have happened
they did um which begs the question like
are they stupid or evil
it's one of those two it's never quite
clear in california which
but that's the woman responsible for the
bill what period what followed uh we
followed after that was
sort of long period of corruption in
which
a bunch of industries came to her and
got exemptions from
the bill pretty much every industry
other than tech for sort of
undisclosed reasons we don't know the
details of any of those meetings or
deals
but certainly tech was the only um
industry that was sort of left out of
that
and so there's just there's history here
between lorena gonzalez and the tech
industry i mean she's clearly at war
with the industry
um it doesn't really make sense to me i
mean if you are
she's a she's a labor activist kind of
socialist light type person
um if you want like i mean if you have
the
the vision of ostensibly what the far
left has which
is like building i mean probably the
steel man version of this is to build
some kind of utopia
um with the wealth of these evil
billionaires in the world
um well you need tax revenue and
the technology industry provides a lot
of it so it's unclear why
these california politicians are so
determined to kick tech out of the state
but they're working on it
um that's like the backstory between
lorena and
like us like the tech industry um but in
terms of the
we begin this we get into this back and
forth she ends up accusing me
actually like it's like an accusation of
being a billionaire
you know being super evil she says i
made my money
off of uh exploiting workers like she
just throws that in there i'm like what
the [ __ ] like
she just goes to nine about this like
about this kind of thing
and um all the talking points you write
down the list but i mean
to even like to like personalize it
though to sort of say
that i made the money off of exploiting
people was super confusing right like
where does that come from
and i think where it comes from is um
she really believes that i think she
really believes what she's saying she
really believes that
the world is filled with like on the one
hand the hyper wealthy and on the other
hand
everybody else this is like i saw this
guy maddie iglesias tweeted not too long
ago and
he's a super lefty but reasonable
sometimes says normal things
this was not one of those times he uh he
was talking about student loan debt he
made this joke
about how he was able to afford to go to
college
because his great great grandfather or
whatever was this like tycoon of
industry
and now i guess maddie has like a trust
fund um and he's like so i don't know
why everyone's complaining about going
to college like they should just do x y
and z you know
be a trust fund kid what he's implying
there is that
um the people who can afford to go to
college
are trust fund kids and then there's
everybody else literally he conceives of
the world
um and this is like rich people do this
um
for sure like this certain kind of rich
person does this but also this certain
kind of like
leftist person does this as well um also
i mean a lot of times
it's one of the same but there's this
belief that the world is comprised
america is comprised of like
trust fund billionaires and then like
hundreds of millions of homeless people
and that's it and um that's just totally
wrong
but that's the belief and so if you you
go after someone for something so in
this case
the fight with lorena and i began when
she went after venture capital and i
went after her legislation i was like
you actually put millions of people
potentially you tried to put millions of
people out of work
with sort of what i implied to her um
and she that was unfathomable to her i
had to either be misinformed
or an evil billionaire that was it those
were the only two things
um i loved at one point where she said
like you were harassing her
i think yeah well that's how it evolves
and that's the next this is a and this
is broader than
than lorena right there's a there's this
trend now
among we've seen it among journalists
not a lot i don't want to like really
just be unfair to journalists um today
uh there are many journalists who are
writing
amazing things they're not super loud on
twitter they're just
they're just you know pen to paper
doing solid work every day reporting on
things that they think are important
even when i disagree with what they
think is might be important like
i there are many journalists who i
respect i respect the way that they work
then there are people who are just on
twitter a lot um stirring up drama
and uh they tend to feel
like criticism of them is
uh nefarious in some way um
if it happens a lot if it's relentless
it must be harassment
and you'll see people complain about
harassment who have for example
200 000 twitter followers and work for
the new york times one of the biggest
media companies
in the entire world um and it's just
like no if you're writing something
on twitter these are people who are
saying things on twitter that are either
unfair or untrue we have to be able to
criticize you and if you're working in
government
um if we elected you to represent us and
we think that you're doing something
wrong
we have to be able to criticize you and
criticism is not harassment
and even insults by the way should be
allowed
especially to our politicians come on
we've made a national pastime of it
and part of what i think is so um kind
of
weird about all of this is this starts
to fall into the camp of like
freedom of speech right and freedom of
speech the in the
kind of classical sense has very clear
uh laws around it has very clear kind of
understanding of what that's supposed to
be
but now we're getting in this like gray
world of like oh you have freedom of
speech
but really only if you say things i like
because i won't come back at you i won't
you know take it a step further i won't
escalate it or whatever so it's almost
like there's
freedom of speech that is protected by
law which is all the important things
that you and i probably put a lot of
weight on
along with a lot of other people but
then there's this like
almost degradation of freedom of speech
when it comes to the gray area
of things that may not be popular or may
not be
uh you know acceptable or agreeable by
certain people and that
to me feels like a slippery slope and
very dangerous
well i think you have political freedom
of speech you have like a
you have like your your legal right to
free to free speech
um and then you have a
culture of free speech and i think that
probably so
a lot of folks on the free speech side
i'm definitely one of them
um have this belief that maybe things
are
much worse today than they've ever been
before uh in terms of what people are
free to say
and culturally and that you know there
was maybe some golden age 100 years ago
or something 200 years ago and
i don't know i think certainly things
feel really they feel worse today than
they did
in our own lifetime maybe 10 or 20 years
ago but also we're now living online so
we're all super super immersed in social
media
and that is a dynamic that is new um
we've never had people clocking so many
hours inside of this virtual space
being just immersed in the opinions of
other people
um i think that human beings have this
natural impulse to try and find
uh consensus among each other it's
probably the super tribal instinct you
want everybody in the tribe to sort of
roughly agree on the same things
and when they don't it's uh alarming and
it
feels wrong well we're now in this like
global
tribe or i mean that's we're not it's a
thing right like you can't have a global
tribe but
i think what's happening online is is
we're trying to come to consensus
with a bunch of people who are never
going to come to consensus
and the harder we try and the worse we
fail at this the more insane we all feel
like we're going and so
you have people who are taking
new actions maybe that they never would
have before so uh we talked about a
political
right to speech that is being attacked
you have
all sorts of people um even in the media
who are
now for the first time in decades
talking about
certainly in my lifetime talking about
normalizing the idea of something like a
hate speech law
so um you know having new classes of
really quote bad speech that are
actually illegal that you can't say
anymore
that is unprecedented in the history of
america and i think
that kind of thing is a natural result
of
people feeling like they're going insane
online
um yeah just just so for people that
don't know
what type of topics would fall in that
so like things that are
uh allowed to be said today but would
now in this new hate speech type
classification not be allowed
you don't have to well these kind of
laws already exist all across europe
and um i think also canada has laws like
this and so
things like any i mean really it's like
anything in the on the topic of race
gender um orientation
are all super off limits uh i think
religion
in in some in some cases um is also
included
uh and is it that you can't talk about
it or that you can't say anything
negative well this is the problem with
this is the problem here is that it's
extremely ambiguous it's you you can't
you can't it's hate speech what is it
what i mean these are the topics for
sure
you are allowed to talk about them you
are allowed to have a like a reasonable
conversation about them
but you can't be hateful about it and
this is like
it comes it can't be targeted it can't
be harassment but but also like i mean
there are certain things you could say
that wouldn't be harassment that are
just not allowed uh
for example um you could say that i
don't know
uh probably in so in the uk you can't
say that
uh i'm trying to give a good one um
that one woman she's like this
conservative person who's always getting
attacked
uh for trans comments uh saying that
it's
it's like [ __ ] or whatever like the
trans thing is fake um
or you know they're they're only two
genders type that kind of a conversation
becomes
super thorny and there's a question of
whether or not you're ginning up hatred
for a minority or
you're trying to have like a reasonable
conversation and so
you get into this really subjective
argument about like what was the
intention of the person
um and i'm sort of over here saying like
it doesn't matter what the intention of
the person was
you should be allowed to say whatever
you want um provided you're not
and this is the allowance that not the
allowance this is the the
this is the one caveat that we seem to
have in this country which is like you
can't be
inciting real world actual physical
violence you can't be requesting people
to go and hurt somebody
you can't be calling people up to hurt
somebody um
it's almost this thing of like you can
hurt somebody's feelings but you can't
you or somebody else can't physically
create violence right and i think that's
where like there will be people who
debate
should you be allowed to hurt people's
feelings whatever that falls into that
bucket which is a whole thing right
i think one of the pieces though that um
i've talked to a couple of guests before
about
is like there is this very very weird
world
of like science and then like what i'll
call like social psychology
right you basically across all these
things whether it's race
gender etc there is a difference
and sometimes it is in the favor of
people that tend to lean left sometimes
it's in the favor of people who tend to
lean right like
there is a difference between the way
that we talk about things in the way
that we think about them and then
science
and in a lot of these my understanding
is that when there is these laws put in
place
it actually bans the conversation around
science as well
right so like when you get to that point
that feels
weird or an overreach or it just doesn't
feel like that makes sense
in some weird way yeah
so dangerous territory um
[Music]
there are a lot of beliefs
on well certainly there are all sorts of
beliefs on the far right that make no
scientific sense whatsoever
but we're allowed to criticize those and
we do all the time
um we've been critiquing christianity in
this country
certainly as long as i've been alive um
you're allowed to
malign that faith as much as you want
you're allowed to align religious
thinking you're allowed to make fun of
creationists
um you are allowed to just go hog on or
go what is the phrase to go ham
just go nuts on taking down faith-based
ideas anti-science thinking from
the right and that also would manifest
in terms of like
uh so you see that in the evolution
debate you would see that
um in just like the the concept of god
itself
um but then also like vaccinations
anti-vac stuff hits a lot of right-wing
people
became a bridge it's also like sort of
crunchy granola type stuff like you see
this up and
my sister lives on one of my sisters
lives on this like hippie island
this yuppy hippy island up off the coast
of seattle called
bashan and it's like filled with
anti-baxters who
who are like super left-wing people but
they don't want to put anything toxic in
their body
so you start to see i mean there's
that stuff exists over there i think the
other there are these
other parts of on the far
left uh these other places where people
are not thinking
where beliefs are at odds with
uh known science um
i think that one of these areas is
gender
i think one of these areas is
probably man i don't even want to talk
about it because it's so dangerous
to talk about i don't know we're not
talking i don't even but i mean i just
like i don't even have
firm beliefs here i have questions
um but it's like these topics are are
off limits um i think and that's the
problem
and that's the problem right let's not
we don't have to go into the individual
topics but like
i think that is ultimately the problem
and the way that
i've heard this best explained is uh i
think it was in the conversation between
joe rogan and kanye west which is like
two people by themselves who are who can
be super controversial depending who
you're talking to
but and i forget which one said it but
they basically like when a topic
enters into an area where you can no
longer discuss it
it is now religion right it you
basically take certainly a dog
yeah it's a dog you take away the
ability to have a conversation around it
yeah well that's the and that was the
goal i mean this is
it's not like it's happening by accident
it's like um
there are certain beliefs that are so
crazy that
the only way for people to be made to
accept them
is for that to be the rule you have to
either accept it or you're kicked out of
the public square
um i i do think i think the gender one
is just the easy it's like that's the
one where
i'm not going to get into a long
conversation about trans
stuff right now you know um but
certainly like separate from the
question of
what had been the trans debate up until
just a handful of years ago which is
concerned something called gender
dysmorphia um which is a
condition that you were diagnosed with
and then there are
there's really only one way that we know
of to alleviate gender dysmorphia it
involves something called transitioning
there's a medical transition and there
are all different sort of
levels of that um but the purpose of
that is to alleviate this thing called
gender dysmorphia well that was
something that we used to talk about
it still exists there are still people
who have that but now there's an
entirely new class of thing
um and it's like i mean this is this is
what
it's like the sort of multiple genders
thing um
and there's just like a whole list of
them all different kinds you gender
gender queer is sort of like the that's
like the ground floor but i mean there
are literally there are lists of
you know famously it's like 86 genders
or whatever which i think is sort of a
pejorative
making fun of an argument but it is like
that world
is very crazy and it also you see where
it really becomes
confusing a lot of that doesn't really
have much to do with science it has to
do with culture
um you know who cares if someone says
they're a new gender it doesn't really
matter and it has nothing to do with
biology
where things become confusing is when
people start talking about
and this is a this comes up quite a lot
the idea that biological sex
isn't real um so now we're sort of
leaving the world of gender they're
really close right
they're sort of like they're like
touching each other right there gender
and sex super related we thought
first step we're told they're decoupled
they have nothing to do with each other
uh that alone i think there's not that
much research supporting
but then where things get really crazy
like i said is is when we start denying
uh the biological sex exists at all and
um it's just really it's just a really
crazy topic
um and you can't even say like hey that
seems
really crazy without uh
without becoming an enemy of some kind
online so i think people just
avoid it so definitely people avoid it
right there's this uh i don't even want
to like you know poke the bear or
or whatever but what i'm more interested
in is like
why right and i always kind of caveat
these conversations with like
i generally find people who are
independent thinkers and kind of
critical thinkers to
one change their minds more than anyone
else in the world
right if they get new information they
change their mind and it's actually a
sign of intellectual
kind of curiosity and honesty that they
will change their mind
uh so i don't think that they're kind of
close-minded people and and they have a
belief in
you know and it becomes dogma for them
the other part of it
is throughout history there's a lot of
ideas that
everyone agrees on today that just
didn't exist before like you can start
with really simple ones like [ __ ]
gravity
right like like there was a time where
like nobody thought gravity did no one
understood it right no one had a name
for it like no one could explain it
but our feet were still planted on the
ground and so like
there's definitely like this evolution
of ideas and people will
go from not understanding something to
understanding something and i think
again critical thinkers independent
thinkers like fully recognize that and
they're actually seeking that
right they want to know the truth well
but so i
you're right all of those things are
true and i think what's interesting
about the gender people
the sort of gender uh maybe like let's
call them gender anarchists for a second
um they are actually the interesting
heretical thinkers here they're the ones
who have a new idea
that is shocking clearly people are
shocked by it and it
you know enrages people online um you
know it's not like these people are
are uh making a lot of friends based on
their ideas it's just that their ideas
are completely protected
it's this weird thing where it's like
this weird case where
the heretical thinker um is
the the thinker with a brand new idea
that has not been tested that makes no
sense
um to the to the common person which
might be right but we don't we've never
heard of it before it's totally new
it's being treated like it's an obvious
scientific fact that has existed
since the dawn of time and that is crazy
and in that part the way that we talk
about it separate from the conversation
separate from the topic itself
the way that we're talking about it
that's
wrong something is like deeply broken
there
flip around and help me understand uh
in terms of the way that you would
expect
that heretical thinkers ideas to kind of
make its way into acceptance in society
how would that normally happen so if it
didn't go from
new idea to immediately protected idea
what would the normal
sequence of events you know just
generally be to getting the acceptance
and then that protection in society as a
kind of consensus thought culturally so
cultural ideas happen slowly and just
who knows it's like a slow process
science scientific ideas
uh that comes down to repeatability so
other scientists running experiments
um that you've run and coming to the
same conclusions
at first science has a long history of
people being dogmatic thinkers within
the world of science and
ostracizing other people who have the
wrong ideas every great scientist that
we know of almost
any certainly anyone with a with a new
exciting idea
they've all been ostracized by by other
scientists by most other scientists
um and then what happens is like
controversy follows their
crazy idea uh and then other people look
at it
and you grow a little following it
doesn't go away
more experiments are run and you kind of
just chip away at what we used to think
and you know 10 years later there's a
new way of thinking about
some topic or other that's how it's
happened in the world of science and so
presumably in the world of
gender and sex you should see something
like that
um here like a slow process
and scientists sort of looking at it and
experiments being run um we don't see
any of that it's it seems like
most of what we're learning about sex
biology today is coming
not from biologists but from social
scientists academics in
the humanities um it is like not
it is it's it's not a serious
biology discussion it's a it's a
cultural discussion
um and one and it's really complicated i
i don't want to speak for you so correct
me if i'm wrong here but i think a very
important part for people who are
listening to this
is uh the way that you're describing
this
tells me it's not whether it's true or
not
right you're not disagreeing or agreeing
necessarily i haven't heard you say
either one of those things
what you're saying is that the work
hasn't been done in a scientific
manner in the way that you would expect
it to be done is that unfair yeah it's
become yeah
i don't i don't know what i think about
this topic honestly um
i what i'm looking at is um
a conversation that is not scientific
and people are saying it's scientific
and in our culture when something is
scientific
it's the law that's the word that we use
to shut down dissent
um and i'm saying that's not we're not
having a scientific discussion here
there are all sorts of topics that we're
not having scientific discussions on
like
like this is one of them they're all
there i mean there's
a wild list of them those tend to be the
craziest uh
sort of hot button issues on the planet
are these places where like
something sort of not quite right is
hiding behind science i think global
warming is one of these not that global
warming
let's not even talk about whether or not
global warming uh is man-made i think
that that
i think that people are definitely
contributing to the warming of the
planet
um i think the carbon has a huge it
seems to me
like carbon uh has a lot to do with the
planet getting warmer
um but presumably if you want to
cool the planet down if that's true we
have too much carbon in the atmosphere
then you want to remove carbon from the
atmosphere or dramatically reduce the
amount of carbon
both really you want to reduce the
amount that we're putting in you also
want to remove it
and so you would think that if we were
having a scientific conversation
about global warming we would be talking
about carbon sequestration
and nuclear energy those would be the
only two things that would make sense
because nuclear energy allows us to
feed eight billion people on the planet
and power them
um without dramatically increasing the
amount of carbon in the atmosphere
uh and carbon sequestration can remove
what we've already put in the atmosphere
but we're not
we're talking about things like solar
and wind and nothing else we're talking
about banning things like
fracking no natural gas which is by the
way incrementally like
much better than oil and coal but like
fracking is going to be banned
uh you know oil is going to be banned of
course uh we're going to just
power our way uh to the future with
solar and wind only we know that that's
not possible um
and no one's talking nuclear is
considered uh
you know a non-starter it's
anti-environmental
um it's unclear why people think that
it's you're not supposed to question it
and then you have uh a complete dearth
of
conversation on carbon sequestration
which begs the question of like
i mean you have people talking about the
end of the world ocasio said
what 12 years or something a few years
ago like
we're getting closer to the apocalypse
every day
just provided the amount of carbon
that's in the atmosphere right now
according to the sort of doomsayers if
that's true
then no amount of energy switching is
going to save us we have to remove
carbon from the atmosphere so if you
believe
these things to be true why can't we
talk about
about the technology that can actually
save us um
it's not a scientific conversation it's
a cultural conversation something else
is happening
there how much of this is um
we have a uh lack of uh
scientifically educated or
scientifically
um kind of competent people so people
who are engaging in the discussion
they don't they're not trained in
science they don't understand science
they don't
uh read the science literature like
they're literally not
uh kind of equipped to have a scientific
conversation versus
no there's actually a lot of people who
have it but they're actually using it
uh to their advantage to have a
conversation that is social not
science i think that the average person
does not want to talk about science and
their brain doesn't really work that way
uh maybe every person doesn't really
work i know it's like
it's not normal to talk about verify
like let's do like repeatability and
let's look at the data and the numbers
when
a topic presents itself to you we have a
gut
reaction to it um it's immediate and
visceral when it's
the the environments uh gender like
we we kind of know what we think about
it before the
but before before we learn anything
about it um
and i think there's like no amount of
scientific training that's gonna
that's gonna change that just based on
you can just look to what we're talking
about before with the way that
almost every single scientist who's ever
come up with something
incredible some new ideas some important
new insight about the world
um who's ever discovered some essential
new truth
they're completely alienated not even so
much by
the average person who doesn't
understand what they're even talking
about they're alienated by
other scientists who are all trained
scientifically no amount of scientific
training
is going to remove from us the impulse
to
root out the wrong thinker that's just
it's like it seems to be innate
we seem to have a sense one of what we
want to believe already
it tends to be based on identity rather
than the facts around us maybe identity
and morality
um and then we look for any evidence we
can to sort of
make arguments that those things are
right
today uh in contemporary american
society
the word science is like a magical word
that carries a lot of power
so everybody fights to use that word
they all fight
to invoke the word science on behalf of
the things that they want to believe to
be true
regardless of how scientific they are um
and so like
yeah we we're never having scientific
arguments i think that
the odds of us ever in the future having
them are pretty slim it's always going
to be an uphill battle
this is not how we're wired i completely
agree
uh why do you have ulysses s grant as uh
your profile picture um
so it started as a fluke i was just
reading the
ulysses s grant biography years ago and
i found it incredibly moving um
he's my favorite president i
was taken by
he was literally a general
like a liberating general he liberated
he ended slavery he was the one on the
grounds who did it he led troops
to shatter the confederacy to bring the
country back together to end
the institution of slavery he went on to
become a president
who supported the gold standard which i
love
um and uh he was
just a cool guy he was just this kind of
like
quiet commander who fought with his
soldiers
in the field of battle for something
that was incredibly important
and yeah i found it i found his whole
entire story
it's really empowering um
and i put up the picture as a joke one
day
it made me feel stronger so like his
suddenly like my face
is gone now it's grant's face um
it's like this old painting so it it
gives him sort of this air of
respectability and um
it's like an appeal to a ancient
knowledge almost is what it feels like
right like we're hearkening back to
something
with that with that guy um
and what i found was i was i started
tweeting
more freely i stopped being so scared to
say what i was
really thinking and i started like
fighting
more for what i believed in which is an
impulse that i've always had i've always
wanted to
um and in the real world i've done it
throughout my life in different ways
but on twitter it was scary and i really
avoided it um
but with grant right there he became
this avatar for me
and um he just
like challenged me to be a little braver
and uh and the more that i was
the more that i said um the more honest
that i was
the more
my twitter seemed to connect with people
i guess
and um and i slowly just
got to be more of myself honestly like
in a weird way by by abandoning my own
image
um i got to
my voice became more authentically my
own and i think that's because
it's like to see your own face there
every day is
really hard you know that people are
looking at you and everything that you
say
is going to be a reflection of you of
that face right there
and in a weird way that like i think
that freezes certainly with me
i found myself frozen like a deer in
headlights like oh my god it feels so
important and if i say one wrong thing
it'll be who i am forever um
regardless of whether or not that's true
certainly grant was
it was like i was able to speak a little
more freely and
and and so then i kept him and he became
he became like
this big part of of who i was
online in a way he was like my internet
my internet bodysuit
um he's my hero i love this answer
yeah you're good that's that's literally
the best answer that anyone could give
for something like that
because it it feels like um it allowed
you to be more you
which is almost what everyone is chasing
and you were able to uh
you know kind of uncover the ability to
do that by simply changing your profile
picture
yeah i think that there's a lot to be
said about this in the way that
teenagers experiment with fashion and
they're like i'm gonna change my name
and i'm gonna be this new thing or
whatever and we all as adults make fun
of that
um and that's wrong it's like actually
what's happening is people feel trapped
inside of their own identities
and they need help breaking free of that
sense that we have of who we are which
is not
entirely correct ever that's always more
about what other people
are putting on you than it is about who
you really are like who you
authentically are
which is probably always changing to a
certain extent um so
like a dramatic change seems dramatic
but actually
it and it seems inauthentic always i
mean you know this kid is sort of like
maybe a nerdy kid
comes to school one day in a leather
jacket and combat boots and you're like
that's not who you are
it's like probably not but he wasn't the
guy yesterday either that also wasn't
who he was
he's looking for room to become who he
is
and that when you change the way that
that you present to people um it gives
you space to become
to become something else who you really
are which is actually why like the trans
stuff is
crazy to me because um i love it like i
actually i'm a transhumanist
i i like the idea that transitioning to
me seems important and good and
being able to change the way that you
present to the world
uh as a way to kind of connect with
quote who you really are
that moves me um and i think that
there's a really important conversation
that's happening there
i think all this stuff is connected and
uh yeah i'm pro it i'm pro
i'm pro changing i'm pro changing i love
it
uh for those that don't know who you are
let's go back to go forwards which is uh
what is your background how'd you get
the founders fund
um so wow long story
let's make it short i met peter thiel
my now boss through a non-profit called
the seasteading institute
these are guys who wanted to build
floating autonomous cities in the middle
of the ocean
the idea was like if
there were just an unlimited so first
open seas no laws out there
theoretically you should be allowed to
sort of collect a bunch of rafts
together in the middle of nowhere
in the ocean and declare it its own
country
um it's like unclear why that wouldn't
be allowed
uh it's kind of like mars when elon musk
gets there and people ask him who's
gonna create the loss and he's like the
people who settle
mars and they get mad at them well so so
what drew me to the c-setting institute
was an essay that peter wrote about it
when he first funded them
way back and i think it was 2008
maybe uh it was called the education of
a libertarian
and in it he talked about mars which had
always been the thing that i cared
the most about and i wanted to go to
mars everything in my life was
i was like that's that's like the most
important thing
um and he was like yeah mars is
important but we're not there
and we are nowhere near there it's going
to be decades if
ever but a frontier is essential we have
to find a new
we have to find a new frontier we have
to open a new frontier
um a new place where there are no laws
there are no structures
it allows people to be creative um when
there's nothing you have to build
something
and if you're building something from
nothing that means that you're doing
something
new like we provided it's like we have
now since the last city has been built
it's been
um well since the last american city has
been built we're talking
150 years or so great american city
uh huge american city uh probably san
francisco would have been the last like
really
massive spectacular american city um and
that was like 18
what 1840s uh the 49ers so it would have
been like
late 1840s 1850s so you want to open a
new frontier
and now you have another 100 years plus
of history
you have a hundred years plus of
technology um what do you build from a
blank slate what what do you create
um so that was the concept of like you
you want to open a frontier how do you
do that
seasteading was this interesting
libertarian
type experiment where it wouldn't just
be one government
it's like a concept and you open up the
seas to
hundreds of new governments and then you
interject you
you uh you you enter sort of like the
market dynamic and
and people will choose of their own free
will which government
is the best so you you do you have a
hardcore like communist government out
there
you have a theocratic government you
have a an anarchist government you have
a sort of
minarcus government and you let them all
you bring back kings you know you have a
bunch of sort of warring kings on their
warring islands um and then people will
just decide what what is the best for
them
and we'll learn a lot it would be this
grand experiment in politics and
that was the sort of utopian dream of
the c-setting institute
um so i volunteered for them because i
wanted to meet
people like that who thought about
things like that i was 23 when i started
volunteering when i
so i think that was like would have been
like 2009. um
and uh and i did i met a i met someone
pretty interesting i met peter
and we became friends and uh
eventually i left the world of
publishing which is where i was working
full-time at the point i was a an
editorial assistant at penguin books
and um and peter brought me to founder's
fund to work on a bunch of projects with
him
do you remember the first conversation
you ever had with him
yeah uh the first real conversation that
wasn't just like uh
trading messages online would have been
um we were at a meet-up that i
threw for seasteading we met in the real
in the real world there um
and we talked about everything i mean we
talked about we talked for like
an hour and a half or something we
talked about politics and philosophy and
we talked about libertarianism and how
it works and why it can never work we
talked about mars
we talked about seasteading um we talked
about the future
broadly big abstract crazy ideas peter's
a
the smartest man i've ever met in my
life and not by a little it's
his brain is like unique and special it
is fast it's like dancing
and he's an interesting dancer like he
comes at topics
sideways it's never um people have this
tendency
in a conversation it's like someone
says something that's maybe a little
controversial and
people will take the other side of that
um and
look i just did it like there's the
implication that there's another side
one other side
and it's obvious and we also i don't
even know where this comes from we seem
to have this reason
we all have this this idea that there's
a we just go to the natural sort of
obvious other side of something and and
everything tends to be super
polarized in this way all conversations
um
and he somehow like just avoids that
dynamic completely and comes at them
from underneath or above or the side and
is
always surprising you in a conversation
and challenging you to
um you know defend what you're saying to
dig deeper to find the meaning behind
something
and that was i mean for me at that time
i i was i never met someone who was so
excited to talk to in my life and
i would have done any any job it
wouldn't have mattered i just
it was like that's i wanna i wanna
learn from this guy what would you say
the number one thing you've learned from
them is
wow there are a lot um if i had to steal
it
one or two it didn't have to just be one
i think that the most important thing he
introduced me to was
the memetic philosophy
there's this guy uh renee girard
not say the most one of the most
important things um and memetic
philosophy is
uh
it concerns it concerns the
natural impulse in people to seek out
competition with each other for
resources
um talks about the way that friends
become enemies
and the only way that we
sort of even know what to want is by
looking to people we respect and value
and we look to them for cues on what to
want and we we
we uh we sort of copy that desire
and we don't even realize we're doing it
uh and we even sometimes think that we
ourselves were the
generator of that desire and that the
other person is copying us
um and it's this really interesting
philosophy that underpins like
everything and it's it
sort of it's a long philosophy there's a
lot there
but you see it manifesting in other
things that he's talked about like
competition is for losers would be the
sort of
meme version of one of the aspects of
gerardian philosophy
you want to avoid competition it's bad
um then you see it manifesting
politically and
uh peter's always talking about war
being bad you know it's one of his huge
things is he's
he's not into war and um you want to
avoid war
um it's never good it's always a waste
of so
it's always like a waste of life and uh
it's always
massively destructive it's unclear if
anything good comes out of most
almost no war um ends in something good
and yet it's like there's this human
impulse towards it
um but the memetic the sort of gerardian
read of all this is that it's
it's all of us wanting to be like each
other wanting to have the same
things that that that we have and um
and it's sort of saying that it's really
hard to find people who are thinking for
themselves
almost ever um and so it really values
well i mean it sort of denies that
original thought even exists but i think
the softer version
of this would be like finding people who
are able to escape
memetic desire even a little bit is sort
of
novel and powerful um you want to find
people who are thinking for themselves
who are looking for new things and it's
actually it sounds almost trite like
this cliche like oh yeah we want like
original thinkers
but it's really really hard most people
are not thinking at all let alone
originally
one of the areas that has very much this
like
polarization and uh tit for tat if you
will
is uh what i'll call tech and anti-tech
and this is playing out across the board
socially
uh politically journalism et cetera i
mean it just
seems to be the the topic du jour if you
will right you see it in
a lot of the anti-trust stuff you see it
in the coverage uh in the media there's
literally
people who tend to be tech friendly and
people who tend to be anti-tech
and then you even see it socially in um
kind of this entire
movement around tech is good for the
world and then literally people
you know tech is bad for the world and
and i think part of
uh what is so unique about that
situation is
uh you have a quote-unquote industry
that is very hard to define right like
is ibm
tech or not right and i think that uh
that makes this difficult but how do you
view kind of that
you know avoidance of that mimetic type
um
relationship when you get tech versus
anti-tech like what is the other
thought process or the other area to
explore
other than just those two like seemingly
polarizing views of the world
well i don't think the anti-tech tech
thing is even about technology
it's about business for sure and
influence and
so actually both sides want exactly the
same thing
it has nothing to do with their
worldview and everything to do with
influence um
they want the new york times wants
exactly what the average like sort of
tech
ceo wants which is the attention of
people um
so that's the first thing if you wanted
to actually break apart
it's hard to break apart the philosophy
of the anti-tech people
for example because like i don't i'm not
really convinced that they have a
problem with any of these things
really i think that we're just in
competition for the same stuff um
let me clarify that because i think it's
an important point you're basically
saying
um you know in kind of a a visualization
if you will
uh there's this treasure chest that has
power
attention influence you know all of
these uh intangibles that people put
importance on
and you basically have two groups of
people who are both uh competing with
each other to who gets the treasure
chest right there's the
quote-unquote uh anti-tech crowd who
usually ends up being uh labeled for
journalists but also there's politicians
etc
but there's also this other crowd that's
competing for that stuff which is
uh just people in business or running
these companies
and so that competition is what drives
the uh
kind of polarization between those two
groups
man it's it's such a complicated fight
honestly so i think that on the one hand
you have that
on not even on v1 as if there are two
there are a lot of so
that is one of the dynamics that's
happening is you have a lot of people
who are fighting for the same
thing which is attention and i think
that actually most that becomes most
pronounced not even among
like tech ceos and journalists as it
does between like
tech influencers in journalists on
twitter that's
that is where a lot of those people are
fighting they're fighting for the same
thing
that those people are like they're i
mean tech influencers are they're
media personalities so they're all
exactly the same
fighting for the same thing which is
attention on the one hand then
in the world of tech it's like
there's technology um and you
ten years ago the conversation was much
more about like
is automation robotic automation good
for the world what about jobs like we
would have conversations like that you
know the robots taking our jobs and i
would get frustrated and be like no
because it's going to create more jobs
and it's going to be utopia and blah
blah blah
we're not even talking about that
anymore we're talking about
basically we're talking about capitalism
versus socialism
every single day and that's a new thing
where where the
the what the technology industry is
ostensibly doing which is
building new technology like that's not
even the topic
so you on the one hand yes you have your
influencers versus your influencers
on on the other you have a little bit
maybe of this of this like
is technology good for the world stuff
um but increasingly now what you have is
a question of
um is business itself
good for the world that is new that's
like these last
i would say under trump really even
before him a little bit but like
uh it's capitalism for socialism i think
you described it
i think that's like the clearest it is
an over generalization
but that is definitely one lens of which
to view the the conversation through
i think it's one yeah i mean and i think
that uh
i think then you then you also have
people in the media who believe their
job
is is just to speak quote like sort of
speak truth to power
and they perceive correctly the
technology industry
uh the technology industry to be an
incredible fountain of power it is
um they fail to acknowledge
that they themselves are also a fountain
power
they get really upset when you point
that out they don't think they have a
responsibility
apparently based on what i'm reading
online um
to wield that power fairly um
and they also tend to like
so i think going after mark zuckerberg
is one thing uh going after facebook
a legitimately powerful company is one
thing i like
mark actually i think mark's doing his
the best job that he can right now
i have a lot of critiques of it but like
i'm not let's just
table the mark zuckerberg conversation
for a second certainly he's a powerful
person
and facebook is a powerful company um
but then you have people going after
like
random ass startups and with like you
know no revenue
and a couple of employees and they're
super
young people who maybe said something
sort of clunky or stupid online and
and it's like well what's happening
there why are they being attacked um
and that i don't know i i don't know uh
that that comes from a place of
like hatred it looks like that i don't
understand and that makes me really
upset and that's
that's what like activated me honestly i
was like like what i started seeing
stuff like that i started seeing
uh media figures going after people who
couldn't defend themselves
from the technology industry who didn't
have much power at all who had no
influence who worked very good with
words and uh it
infuriated me and i was like this is
[ __ ] if if they can't fight for
themselves
um i'll do it for them whatever i'll
clap back i don't care
so i'm gonna ask you to uh take a couple
different perspectives here because i
think that this conversation is really
important and
uh seeing it from multiple sides which i
think you actually do that's why i want
to talk to you so
let's go to um the defense first of the
media industry you already said earlier
like there are
many many good journalists who do good
journalism and whether you agree with
them or not i think people place an
incredible amount of importance on those
journalists right like the freedom of
the press
the ability to uh publish things that
even if people don't want it published
like
that is protected uh they do the right
things in terms of the amount of work
and checking facts and all that stuff
and they publish it
i think you fall in that camp but
correct me if i'm wrong in terms of like
there are important people doing that
stuff
how do you if you had to put together an
argument to defend
the people who aren't necessarily doing
the hardcore journalism but are still
publishing at media sites so i usually
call these like the bloggers
masquerading as journalists right
they're not actually doing journalism it
is published under the news it is
published under
you know non-opinion type sections yeah
i think that's like most of
the so the new york times is a great
let's just go to the new york times
um the new york times so they have an
influencer
i mean we can just call what it is they
are going around and they're hiring
personalities
who are creating content that
peop they want people to read that run
them into the paywall and get people to
subscribe which by the way
is perfectly fine it's actually a great
media strategy like like that is
if you're the running the new york times
that's actually like the strategy you
probably should be doing
in today's day and age right right it's
just it just cuts against
so all of those people the reason that
they're so powerful
those that certain kind of media
influencer they're they're powerful
because they're not just people with
opinions they're
people with opinions standing behind the
new york times
and the new york times carries with it
this incredible
air of um fairness of
uh seriousness of like you know
verifiability um accountability they are
quote the paper of record which i've
seen some of these people whip out in
conversations online before as a defense
of some dumb thing that one of them did
like how dare you this is the paper of
record and it's like wait a minute
you're just an [ __ ] on twitter as am
i like
what does the new york times have to do
with it i don't care that you work there
it doesn't make you a better person it
doesn't make you smarter it does not
make you
better at your job it doesn't make you a
better writer that's for sure um
but but like at the new york times that
brand has come
from like decades and decades and
decades
of serious journalism now within that
world of serious journalism there are
all sorts of problems there's this
question of like
was there ever a time when the new york
times really didn't have a bias
of course it was biased you can't even
decide
on what stories to cover unless you have
a bias you need a bias
to make those kinds of determinations
and the entire con the the
entire idea of a
media company that was without bias is a
weird historical aberration it's a
product of the 20th century
um really like you saw it like
hugely uh sort of come together under
world war
ii and after when you had this massive
consolidation of media entities
and the government sort of gets involved
and and is like you need to be like fair
and neutral and all this [ __ ]
they're all it was history it was
historical virtue signaling that's
basically what it was it was a way to
virtue signal saying that we are
unbiased but
naturally if you have an organization
run by humans you can't be unbiased
possibly i think it's some of that i do
think that real efforts were made
to try and it was this really noble
thing people were like how do we just
report objectively
um and it's like well you can't decide
on what to cover objectively
that comes that's a subjective decision
is there a way to cover
the thing that you decided on
subjectively objectively
that's a weird question because clearly
you have a lot of feelings about the
thing that you're covering
and so likely you have an opinion about
it um i think it's really noble i
i was talking to a chronicle reporter um
for a project i was working on like a
year ago
i was at city hall talking to her she
wouldn't even take opinions on
the supervisors and deeply cared about
this
and was committed to it committed to the
idea of like principled
objective reporting on on city council
and i love that i love those people
i think they're important and i think
those people still there are
many of them that still exist in the new
york times you who at least believe
that who at least are trying to be as
objective as they can
covering these things even though i
think it's not entirely possible
but they're trying and they are doing
good work and they're doing work that i
like i'm writing now on my sub stack
i find myself going back to their work
all i'm always linking back to work
that's
that is written and published in the new
york times there's tons of great stuff
there
on the topics of like china um for
example comes to mind
there's all sorts of uncovered there
there's been plenty of great reporting
um on uh on ufos like
everything good every piece of good
reporting on ufos
has come from the new york times and um
and so there's a lot there
but then you have these influencers who
are increasingly dominant um
they're clearly not here to sort of
serve the public with information that
is in the public's benefit they're there
to either become
sort of famous influencers or to push
some kind of
propaganda um and in the tech team at
new york times i mean you have a couple
people who are
decent um who i think really believe
that they're gonna cover the industry
objectively they happen to believe the
industry is too powerful and too
dangerous so like
it's always a negative frame but that
having like
knowing that it's always a negative
frame i think there are a couple people
there with that negative frame
who are at least still fair uh but
most of them are not that most of them
are assassins most of them are looking
to
malign and ridicule uh people like in
any way they can from our industry
most of them have a super anti-business
bias
most of them think that we're the reason
they are miserable
um and then also they get a lot of
attention online
for their ridiculous takes and flame
wars and so that's what they do that's
what they're
they're incentivized to they are uh
incentivized to do
what's the solution well what's the
problem first of all i guess that's the
more i mean is this a problem
like we've seen crazy media ecosystems
like this in the past we saw this in
i mean like i said throughout most as
long as there's been a press
with a slight historical aberration in
the 20th century
like it's mostly been this crazy mess of
warring outlets
and like media figures attacking each
other most of our founding fathers
were part of this dynamic by the way in
america like how many of them had their
own newspaper how many of them
were penning in like six different pen
names and were just like mercilessly
attacking
their opponents like that was the news
it was opinion was the news
what's changed is now in the world of
technology there's so much more that's
being written there are so many more
people who are activated
and we're also sort of all living you
know used to be able to pick up a
newspaper and put it down
now it the news the news walks around
with us wherever we go and it infects
everything um so it's it feels
it feels really different i think it's
not different it's just
bigger um and
the solution i think is like
people accept that that's reality people
have to start accepting
that there is no objective source of
news um there are facts and there are
some people who are reporting on facts
but it's really really hard to get it
at something that is completely without
bias
and so knowing that it's you have to
start sort of looking for multiple
sources on any given story
um this is something that i do myself
like if i find if i find a story that
i love that confirms all of my biases um
that's when i get most nervous and i'm
like all right don't tweet about it just
yet
because you want this to be true so go
find
some other source go look click through
some of these links that
where did this come from what else did
that person write it's really hard
everything inside of me wants to not do
that but but you have to
try and i think that we have to
normalize that we have to normalize
um the assumption that most of what
we're reading is a little bit untrue
at all times and if we can do that if
that becomes
a normal cultural thing then then maybe
this discourse improves a little bit i
think it's the single most important
thing that can happen
is a uh kind of hard right
into independent thinking and uh
literally training people
you know i don't know where and when you
do that if that's in like grade school
or if that's you know
somewhere in uh social media school or
whatever but just this idea of
uh seeking out you know multiple
opinions on a topic
uh before kind of originating your own
ideas or conclusions
uh could go very very far away uh for
every population or subpopulation in the
united states and globally
it's just like you said it goes against
everything in human nature right
yeah i mean this is not how this is not
this is not how we do
we don't want to learn new things we
don't want to think about anything that
challenges our core assumptions about
the world
um once we decide that someone is bad
our assumption is that everything they
say is bad everything they do is bad
uh and i mean that's like
that alone is is most of what's
happening right now with tech vs
versus the press is like both camps have
already decided that the other camp is
totally bad
and i mean i happen to i'm clearly on
the tech side
i have a lot of reason to believe that
the press um
wants to destroy us uh a lot of times
they say it just like on twitter they
talk about
the need to reduce the power and
influence of tech and blah blah blah
they're super pro antitrust they were
pro 85
after they got their own exemptions uh
they were anti-prop 22 which would have
i mean had prop 22 in california failed
uber and lyft probably would have had to
have shut down in the state of
california
so i'm looking at what they're saying
and arguing for and i'm like
you're you know you're trying to destroy
us so like i'm
we're at war but it's complicated and
there are lots of journalists and
they're not all like that and if they
liked one bad article or
or wrote one bad article um
or got into one weird argument online
and i saw that and i
mean that's wrong it's wrong for me to
to lump i get that that's wrong
um but human nature of human nature it's
human nature all right i want to finish
up talking about
uh a subject that i did not know that
you were uh fond of but somebody
told me this when they saw that we were
gonna talk which is aliens
and uh and ufos uh and then you were
talking about mars
earlier uh at the end of every interview
i asked people whether
uh they believe in aliens or not uh and
this all came out of one day i was
laying
in bed about a fall asleep and uh i just
thought to myself i said do you think
aliens have pets
like if they showed up on earth right
would they be showing up with like
multi-species type
you know uh you know situation going on
and like a dog on a leash like that
like i've never seen that in any of the
sci-fi like that's a weird thing to
think about
uh where does your fascination with
aliens ufos kind of outer space other
planets etc come from
and kind of what just start talking
about that in general and like
what fascinates you about it well all
right so my interest in
mars is completely different than my
interest in ufos um
mars for me is a and i'm not like oh i
want to go to mars it's like
the exciting thing about mars is we have
a blank slate we can we can
create an entirely new world right we're
talking about
go to mars terraform build an atmosphere
create atmospheric pressure
walk around without masks on maybe like
a little bit of an oxygen
sort of like thing in your nose but like
your mask is off now you're protected
from
the radiation you
are looking around a world that's you
know your atmosphere is mostly carbon
dioxide
plants are growing oceans ice is melted
we have oceans on mars like
i look at mars and i see a future that
is
incredible and it's this incredible
opportunity
to create a new branch of human
civilization
and um and that's always been my
interest in mars it's always been super
uh human-centric it's been
super humanist it's been about us ufos
and aliens so aliens i don't believe in
aliens
belief i i'm neutral on aliens i don't
believe yes and aliens
um i have no idea i think there's no
evidence either way ufos
are definitely real ufos are happening
the question is what are they
and the fascination for me with ufos has
nothing to do with aliens it it or even
the ufos themselves what is blowing my
mind is the way that people refuse to
look at it
it's like how much evidence do you need
how many like
pentagon programs how many new york
times breaking stories about scientists
working
on this like with sort of i mean and
you have to go back and you should read
the new york times articles they are
insane uh the interviews that they have
with like
it is pilots uh material scientists
you have people who have are ex pentagon
officials like
what they're talking about first of all
it's like it's not just photographic
evidence and video videographic evidence
and the accounts of pilots um there's
also talk of like
material retrieved from a crash like in
the pages of the new york times this is
just
a year ago less than a year ago this
happened under covid uh the materials
piece
and it's like that's really crazy um
we have to know everything that we can
about that there are all sorts of things
that are not being disclosed
from the government still so i'm like
clearly we should be demanding complete
transparency at this point
um ufos there are only a couple of
options here it's like
either yeah it's aliens um okay that's
crazy
or probably what seems a little more
likely at least it did
to me until i started looking into this
was oh wow you know russia and china
super technologically advanced
um one i don't think that's true but if
it were true that would be a
huge story worth talking about the fact
that russia and china have
the technology to travel faster than
you know the speed of sound in ways or
i'm sorry uh they have the technology to
accelerate in ways that seem to defy
the known laws of physics like that's a
big deal um
three it's a massive conspiracy also a
huge deal
like there's there's no version of this
story that isn't like the biggest story
in the entire world
uh so why don't people want to know
more about it why does
every time this like a crazy
well-sourced article on ufos come out
again this is in the new york times
right like this is a new world that
we're living in now
in the 90s it was not like this in the
early 2000s it was not like this
we're looking at stories that are coming
out now in
that are well sourced um that have
evidence sometimes videographic evidence
embedded in the piece
like why do we talk about it on twitter
for a day and then the next day we
it's like we don't even remember that it
happened what is that what's that
phenomena that's what i can't stop
thinking about
is it because people just assume that it
that like yeah of course ufos exist and
and uh that's already kind of been
ingrained in people's heads because they
saw the leaked videos on reddit
four years ago or whatever and it's just
like oh yeah it's old news
or is it that it scares people and they
don't want to know or is it something
else i i don't know what the answer is
but like what's your opinion
i think people don't believe it's i
think people believe it's too crazy to
be real
i think that it's it seems too crazy
they're waiting for
something to come out that explains it
all away
and my feeling about the world is it's
much stranger
than we think and i think that
the ufos to me it's
i think the most likely thing is that
we're looking at some kind of natural
phenomena
that changes the the rules
so to speak of physics um
and reality like i think there's
something i think that reality
is much more complicated than we think
um and i think that there's something in
the ufo stuff that's that fundamentally
alters our conception of the world
if we would explore it if we would look
at it if we would learn about it it
would change
i think everything um and i think people
on some level know that
they know that so they're waiting for it
to be written away
but if it's not if it can't be if it
changes
everything that we know about ourselves
that's really exhausting
and people have evolved in such a way as
to conserve as much energy as possible
we don't like to change we don't like to
change the way we think about things
we don't like to change physically like
there's there's we don't like to change
in
sort of any sense of the world word we
do not like changing because changing
requires energy and um and energy
the difference between a lot and little
in the paleolithic era
was the difference was the difference
between um
passing on your genes or not right um
our ancestors were lazy that's why they
survived we're lazy we don't want to
learn about the world
this is just that's what they're scared
of it's less about the aliens than it is
about
what they're going to have to do
themselves which is think about the
world
for themselves is it fair to say that
the ufos are literally the you know the
the terminology unidentified flying
objects uh
their ufos until we figure it out and so
if it was alien spacecraft right kind of
the idea of a ufo or at least in
what we're calling ufos today that goes
away and it becomes alien spacecraft
if it's a technological superiority from
another foreign country or whatever
then like we almost are in this weird
state
of um not understanding it that's why
it's a ufo but once it is understood
therefore it gets labeled something else
or do you think
that we live in this weird world where
there's such a fascination with ufos
that like even if
uh it was alien spacecraft or you know
technological superiority like people
would still call this stuff ufos
well what they're calling it now is the
pentagon has sort of switched
the game up here uh we've gone from ufos
unidentified flying objects to uaps
unidentified aerial phenomena
uh that's like the sort of new
nomenclature which broadens it doesn't
narrow it
uh and it broadens it to include i mean
who knows what all manner of things
um if it's not it's not like objects the
question is like is it even physically
there
like is it in this dimension i mean who
know there are all sorts of wild
conversations that you can have about
this
um i do think
that no i think that if we have a better
sense of what it is
we'll have a new word for it and i think
that our language does yeah it allows us
in some way to to
we're constricted by our language um
i think that uh i don't i think that
we're gonna learn a lot i think the next
five years are going to be insane for
ufo stuff there's a lot of information
that government is hiding but there's
also stuff like as more people
start to look at this as more people now
believe that it's interesting i think
the average person
is like shut down they're like nope
that's impossible um
don't have to think about that not worth
my energy
there's a minority of people and that
minority is growing by the day
um who are no longer it's not like your
tin foil hat wearing people it's people
like us who are like um okay i'm looking
at this information
it seems weird i would like to see more
information
and uh that means that people are going
to be gathering more information
that means that people are going to be
requesting more information that we
already have that's just being hidden
specifically so the naval uh the navy's
been really open about
their information the pentagon has been
a little bit more closed and then the
air force is like totally dark
we there's a lot of information i think
that the air force is sitting on well
what do i know i'm just a guy on twitter
i have no idea what the air force does
or does not know
you're a sub stack billionaire on
twitter make sure we uh
classify you correctly i want to spend
the last minute or two talking about
uh the content you consume uh you are uh
obviously an original thinker kind of
very open-minded
and my guess is that you consume very
different types of content whether it's
books news outlets podcasts
you know whatever what are the things
that kind of come to mind when i say
like what content do you consume
on a periodic basis um i read a lot of
books
i'm i think every week i've got a couple
i'm not
i don't get through them i think this is
something that you have to sort of do if
you don't like a book
it's not your fault it's the book's
fault just put the book down like
and that's great so reading through
books is how i find other books that i
want to read it's like i could become
interested in a topic and
i'm like oh cool i don't know anything
about that what
and i go and i buy a book on it um i
so it's like yeah lots of stacks and
stacks of books ever i mean that's just
a few of them a lot of those are
encyclopedias i just got those because i
no longer trust wikipedia
so i want like an older hardbound source
of knowledge that i can
go back to um and then i can sort of
compare that with new things to sort of
get a rough approximation of what is
real
uh so yeah books is a big one
what type of books non-fiction now i
used to be super into fiction
um these days it's like non-fiction
bio biographies for history and then
also um
older stuff uh classics um
but yeah it's it's a broad thing i mean
it's everything from just like
yeah it's like non-fiction to the
classics to uh
when you when you wake up what's the
news sources that you check first
twitter i go to twitter like an [ __ ]
um everybody does it nobody wants to say
it but everyone does it
yeah so it's like books for directed
learning and then twitter for passive
learning
twitter is like where i keep a sense of
so i keep up with a sense of what's
going on
and that's usually what i'm talking
about it's what i'm i'm like responding
to those
dialogues online um but it's not really
where i go to learn about the world it's
where i go to learn about what people
think about the world
which is really important i'm in media
increasingly and
i really care about the stories that
people tell themselves i think that that
shapes our entire reality so
twitter is for me where our entire world
is being built right now
which is why it's so exciting it's why
people can't look away we all kind of
have a sense of that we know that that's
where
everybody who is involved in the sort of
like
creation of our world they're all on
twitter right now and they're all
reading the same
trash fire content and that's informing
everything
so it's like yeah it's just like
self-directed learning with books
twitter for the trash fire
uh of the day and um
i'm not really a big podcast guy
actually i've got a handful that i
listened to
um but nothing that i'd want to share
that's like so great i like to produce
podcasts but
um it sounds so stupid but i actually as
someone who
does create podcasts there are not many
that i am
super obsessed with myself last question
for you that i'll let you go uh if you
had to choose one sentence
a quote a sentence whatever that you
live your life by or a motto
what would it be
that's a big request for
out of nowhere um
well the one that comes to mind is just
fortune favors the bold that's a great
one
it's even better that you thought of
that right off top of your head
and that's that i mean that's what i've
got i i hope that was uh
enough for you um dude this is fantastic
i never thought that i would talk to a
substance billionaire who was such an
independent thinker
and also at the same time had so many
controversial thoughts
all right man well thank you for having
me and i'm stoked to see how it comes
out and
if you wanted to record more on like
certain questions or whatever i'm down
awesome where can we send people to find
you uh on the internet
let's go to my twitter which is mike
selana m-i-c-s-o-l-a-n-a
uh so it sounds like mick mic sol ama um
or my sub stack is solana
solana.substance.com
awesome man well thank you so much we're
going to do this again the future thank
you yeah i'll talk to you later